[Music]
thank you
Hello friends thank you for joining us
here in this another program that is one
of your favorite programs and one of
ours too it's called I like to know I Am
David Salazar and I'm delighted to be
able to share this time of study of
answering your questions with a
wonderful guest and Speaker of course a
part of our some TV family Pastor CA
Murray Pastor welcome to this program
good to be here as always good to study
the word of God thank you Pastor Israel
always a delight for us to be able to
share this program with you because we
receive your questions your inquiries
and we try to do your Justice by
answering them according according to
the word of God according to the
knowledge that he has inspired us to
receive and we promise you that we'll do
our best in answering we are not
infallible we are still human beings we
can make mistakes we might not be able
to have all the answers but we try to
submit to the leading of the Holy Spirit
and we pray that this program these
questions will be a blessing as we
answer them we'll be everything to you
those that are listening remember that
you can send your questions your
inquiries to TV at
samtv.org you can send your question or
your inquiry or your concern about what
the Bible says to this address TV at
some tv.org before we start Pastor if
you don't mind lead us into prayer as we
need the Lord's guidance as we open the
God's word my pleasure to do so father
God again we praise you and thank you
for your word which is truly a lamp unto
our feet and a light into our path we
are thankful Lord that the word can be
studied that we can eat the word as it
were consume the truth of the word and
grow spiritually mentally and physically
amen as we draw closer to you and as we
understand your will for our lives we
ask that you would bless this program
May Christ be seen and heard and felt
and glorified through all that is said
and done and we thank you in Jesus name
amen amen amen thank you Pastor for that
wonderful prayer now let's go into the
questions pastor we have today hopefully
we can reach uh more than a couple today
we'll see what other Lord leads us here
if you don't mind leading us with the
first question alrighty this is from
Renee from Washington State
his question is
it is true that God knows the past the
present and the future
it is also true that he knows who will
be saved and who will not be saved so
why do we keep praying for our families
who may or may not be saved if they are
going to be saved praise the Lord if
they're if they are going let's see if
they're going to be saved praise the
Lord if they are going to be saved but
if they're going to be lost do we change
God's Mind by praying that they may be
saved when ultimately they will choose
to be lost
interesting question Pastor so he's from
what I gathered he's concerned about
should we pray for family members
if God ultimately knows their fate who's
going to be safe who's going to be lost
will it mean that
if we pray for them that are right now
not being you know that are not in the
faith will they be persuaded to change
if we pray to God so he can change his
mind or are we doing this in vain I
guess the question is that so what do
you take on this what is your first
impression about this
to begin
I would say
God knows but we do not know
[Music]
when you look at it from the end and I I
hope you understand me Rennie
um
you can say well it's all going to end
up this way so there's no no sense going
through the process
but God wants us to go through the
process also because that does a number
of things one it develops a relationship
with God you see God just doesn't say
okay you're saved and you're in God
wants the relationship and the
relationship is the process now God also
knows who's going to take time to
develop during that process so every
prayer you pray God takes into account
and knows it he didn't he doesn't catch
it by surprise so all of these process
types of things have to be done and it
is the process that ends in Salvation so
God wants us to go through the process
because it is in going through the
process that we develop relationships
it's not just about getting saved it's
about developing a relationship with the
Lord and uh it is the relationship that
ends in Salvation amen so you can't skip
the process absolutely it just goes
directly to Salvation God wants you to
entertain the process because that's how
you get to know him how he becomes your
friend and your savior and as we say the
personal friend the personal savior of
each and every individual you cannot
skip the process Pastor I think you have
a very good point uh as you're actually
saying this it makes perfect sense to
understand that our process our own
personal process of of salvation of
Redemption of being able to have the
character of Christ to love our
neighbors to love our loved ones to love
the men and of course love God will
reflect in US pursuing the Lost
seeking you know to save him not ceasing
to do good to them and present the truth
to them and pray for them yes so whether
or not they are ultimately laws or say
because they reject the opportunities it
is us who are called to pray for them
yes you know perfect this is called us
you know pray for those that persecute
you that those that are doing you harm
that say all matter of focus you know
pray for them so if we're called to pray
for the wicked for the loss or for those
family members who are not following the
Lord we are to understand that is
because it helps us in our relationship
as you Riley said so in trusting in
loving the Lord and having that
character that Christ had yes When you
pray for your brother for your sister
for your friend for your loved one for
your co-worker
it not only helps them it also helps you
absolutely you know God has designed
that mankind be intimately involved in
the salvation of other men and women so
praying for them is not just okay it
gets them in but it draws you closer to
the Lord again again you you can't gain
say the the process because God wants a
relationship with you now here and now
that will be cemented in eternity but
you're choosing God here and now you're
spending time with God you're knowing
what God is like you're receiving
blessings from God you're receiving the
power and friends of his holy spirit
right you're receiving Grace to meet the
challenges of each day so it's not just
about looking at the ultimate in it's
about the process now
sometimes we mistake predestination for
predeterminism you know and they are not
the same I've got a quick quote that I
just wanted to to read from from uh
um
Ellen White written June 11
1902. uh the predestination or election
of which God speaks excuse me
includes all who will accept Christ as
personal savior
who will return to their loyalty to
perfect obedience to all of God's
Commandments this is the effectual
salvation of a peculiar people chosen by
God from among men
all who are willing to be saved in
Christ are the elect of God
it is the obedient who are predestined
from the foundation of the world to as
many as receive him to them gave you the
power to become the sons of God even to
as many as believed on his name so the
the prerequisite for salvation
experience is surrender and receiving of
Jesus Christ amen that has been
predestined from the foundation of the
world that if you receive Christ if you
live in Christ and die in Christ you
shall live forever that's the only thing
that's predetermined so once you step
into that path into that trough right it
is predestined that you will end up in
glory because the way has been
predestined right but whether you're
going to walk in the way is up to you
exactly that's your choice absolutely
thank you Pastor and you know what you
mentioned right here also helps us to
understand how the Lord really deals
with us because the question certainly
the question that that our friend rainy
had it's in regards to you know how if
God knows the past the friends and the
Future Would it makes sense for us to
pray for somebody that is going to be
ultimately lost now I think that to
understand it sort of questions a little
bit of the character of God but I
believe Christ gave us a very clear
example in his own life with one of his
own
remember when Christ actually in John 6
64 it says there but there are some of
you that believe not for Jesus knew from
the beginning who they were that believe
and who should betray him so Christ yes
he knew that
from the beginning one of the 12 he knew
that Judas would betray him but did
Christ act any differently did he stop
really loving him giving him you know
the attention as he was gonna be the one
that betrayed him of course not you're
right so the contrary Christ did the
most to save and appeal to his soul to
turn to him to come to him to accept him
as the Savior to really be able to
uh realize that his way his rejection of
truth will lead him to the Perdition
until the very end in John 13 we see you
know the Lord even while she's on his
his foot you know he his feet he wanted
to wash the feet of the disciples he
watched the feet of Judas
appealing trying to show him that
his way you know he was willing to give
his life forth than him nevertheless
Judas unrejected so the way that Christ
dealt with Judas to me gives us an
example of how the Lord will deal with
every person including those that will
betray him yes yeah he will not stop
loving them he will do all that he can
to persuade him to come to him to
persuade them to accept him
ultimately is the choice of the person
the individual who says
I don't want to follow the lord the
fault is not on the Lord God you know
and that's one thing we have to be very
clear that God is not the one that's
going to stop doing everything to
persuade somebody to attract to the Lord
but it's going to be the choice of the
individual who puts him you know away
from God so God will never stop doing
and working towards saving this lost
that's something that he says you know
so we have to just think that way and do
our part and do the same you know we we
are uh told in a certain prophecy that
we are a lesson book to the universe God
knows but no one else in the universe
knows but God so there are those who are
watching and looking in on this so God
is doing all he can when the records are
examined no one can say well Lord you
didn't give him a fair chance you knew
he wasn't going to make it so you kind
of kicked him to the curb no
um we find in in Ellen White's writings
particularly in both these are of Ages
that
Judas had a problem with money and and
and a lot of his his
fall was was paid to his his un
inordinate Love of Money yes
um he was willing to follow Christ but
when it came to money he felt Jesus
should line up behind him you know Jesus
ought to take advice from me because
these disciples went to Junior College
Community College I went to Harvard you
know I got the education there I'm the
smart guy and and and he always he
always profited himself that way
Christ knew he said have not chosen you
all u-12 and one of you is a devil so he
knew he was dealing with so what did he
do he put Judas in charge of the money
you know so he's giving a guy an
opportunity to correct his fault so I'm
not you know Salvation Pastor is not
avoidance theology it's it's meeting the
the the the problem head-on and
overcoming the problem you know if if
I've got a problem with drinking I
should stay away from it uh and I
shouldn't go through it but um
at some point in my life I've got to say
no to alcohol absolutely and it's going
to be no next time no well Judas is in
charge of the money he's stealing from
the from the little bag he's embezzling
the money he had an opportunity to
correct his fault and Christ gave him
that opportunity but he didn't he didn't
take it he didn't Avail himself of it
he made as my mom used to say his own
bed he had to lie in it you know that
that kind of thing but but but Christ
gave him every opportunity so in
eternity when someone looks at the
records and says okay Judas Judas Judas
Judah Judas no he gave him every
opportunity he had every opportunity and
he didn't Avail himself of that
opportunity so Christ is about letting
this Saga play out in the lives of his
people and giving us every opportunity
every chance to be saved and to develop
a relationship with amen and you know
the way that the Lord dealt with him at
the very end uh it speaks of
his his love for him actually in John 13
verse 21
he says when it says Bible there when
Jesus had thus said he was troubled in
spirit and testified and said verily
verily I sent to you that one of you
shall betray me this expression he was
trouble in spirit is not he was angry or
that he was somehow like you know
puzzled right it means that he was in
agony he was broken he was
deeply sad and moved you know by the
fact that before him there was a man who
had all the opportunities in the world
to recognize his mistake his sin and
accept the wonderful savior but he
rejects that and Christ is
almost weeping he's broken in his spirit
because of what's Happening
because of the fact of that man choosing
to go against the will of God so I think
that ultimately we see the character of
God how he deals with those that sadly
will be lost he will continue to the
very end to try to pursue them to bring
them to attract them to himself as he
has promised so I think that we can
safely say that the best scenario is to
continue to pray for those that are
around us to love them yes and never
give up God has not given up on them and
we don't know when that will happen so I
mean he's never going to give up on them
but when you know when his time of Grace
will come to an end that's when
everybody had made a decision the
ultimatician forever for life and until
then we are to continue no no matter the
the what we may perceive as the case yes
you know he says do we change God's mind
may I respectfully suggest that is not
God's mind that needs to be changed
exactly it's the mind of The Sinner amen
now will they change or not God knows
that but it's still the decision of The
Sinner that's right to make that change
whatever that change is God knows it but
God is not going to
pre-effect that he leaves it open to the
center amen the The Ellen White says
that that Christ
wept over Judas cared about Judas as you
well said was disturbed by him up until
the very end until he left that dinner
and walked out and and and and and
ratified that that that deal Christ was
still pleading for him amen and and
wanted to save him but he made the
decision Christ did not predetermine his
decision even though he knew what that
decision was going to be amen yeah well
said pastor all right let's go to the
next question and let's see this
question this is an interesting question
uh comes from Gene and it tells us the
following
would you please go over the three days
and three nights of Jesus in the grave
because it it's hard for me to figure it
out
is it possible to consider Friday in the
biblical way and considered Friday as
starting on Thursday evening as we
consider in fact for the Sabbath in
crucifixion period
so that's the question that they have
about the three days and three nights
and I think this is uh you know Gene is
telling us from the expression that
Jesus has in John 12 that's where a lot
of people
you know have made this argument or this
issue among Christians uh Christ in
Matthew 12 40
is speaking of the context of this story
and I think it's important to to see the
context crisis speaking to the Pharisees
and in verse 40 says or actually I'll
read 39 and 40 and he answered and said
unto them an evil and adulterous
Generations seek it after a sign and
there shall no sign be given to it but
the sign of the prophet Jonah for us
Jonah was three days and three nights in
the whale's belly social the son of man
be three days and three nights in the
heart of the earth so this is the
expression
that confuses a lot of or or has
established a kind of a debate debate
among some Christian you know uh people
did that in regards to did Christ spend
three days and nights as he's mentioned
here on
the tomb and I think that the first is
State Pastor is that they're assuming
that what Christ says here in the heart
of the earth equals the tomb and they
assume well he has to be 72 hours and so
he has to spend there the night and
obviously as we go through uh we don't
have time to go through the all the
nurses but we're not clearly from
scripture that Christ died was crucified
on Friday
and he died and around the third hour in
the afternoon
so that means that you know uh he died
in the afternoon Friday and he
restricted on the first day which is
Sunday so the question is how can we
have three days three nights if he died
on on Friday but the key thing I believe
and you predominantly you go for the the
key thing is what does the heart of the
Earth really mean you know is it really
talking about being in the Tomb and I
think that's the kind of the mistakes
the expression heart of the earth is not
necessarily having to be
in the grave what is it what are your
takes on on this you know I it's
interesting that you came to that that
conclusion because I did several years
ago in wrestling with this that I I for
one of a better terms start the clock
ticking on heart of the Earth on the
time he's taken by uh the priests and
and his his Liberties are restricted he
is no longer free to do what he wants he
has he has been
hijack kidnap say what you want and and
I start the clock kicking then
I think he is right it is evening and
morning on the first day we get that
from Genesis uh chapter 1 verse five so
right we're dealing with uh people who
are writing who already understand that
that a day begins in the evening of the
previous day this idea is starting 12
o'clock midnight I'm not sure it doesn't
I don't remember when exactly it came in
but that's not biblical Reckoning
absolutely so uh the Sabbath we know
begins Friday evening to Saturday
evening and of course all of the days
following that same that same pattern
yes so he's taken uh Thursday evening
begins Friday Begins the preparation day
Friday evening begins Sabbath Sabbath
evening begins Sunday right so he is
technically in this confined condition
from
um
the afternoon through
uh two and a half days later when he
comes out on Sunday morning now on
Sunday morning of course half of Sunday
has already been consumed right so it is
if you look at inclusive Reckoning right
three days absolutely or the better part
of three days absolutely and I think
that you make a very good point uh some
people think or use the Expression heart
of the earth to think it has to be in
the Tomb but is nowhere really that the
case if we go actually to the you know
Christ
uh
pre-announced or he prophesied up to his
disciples that he was going to be
crucified and resurrected in three days
at the third day and usually
the three times that he shares to
disciples that you know tells him I'm
gonna be crucified or I'm gonna be you
know resurrected in the third day it
always talks about first being given to
the elders and to the Chiefs and to the
Pharisees under the priests he never
divides the two parts he's not like he's
saying I'm gonna you know I'm gonna die
for three days we can go actually go to
Matthew chapter 16 the first time that
he mentions that verse 21
um and then we can go to Matthew 17 22
and maybe you can read them you know to
one of you
you can read 1621 you have Diamond
password I should do all right from that
time Jesus began to show to his
disciples that he must go to Jerusalem
suffer many things from the elders and
the chief priests and scribes and be
killed and raised the third day so it's
inclusive
um go to Jerusalem suffer
be raised the third day so the clock
starts ticking at at be at suffering
exactly and it ends at raised so it's
all inclusive and in exactly and that's
why the second time the same thing verse
chapter 17 22 and 23 he says and while
they are voting Galilee Jesus said unto
them the son of man shall be betrayed
into the hands of man and they shall
kill him and the third day he shall
raise be raised again so you see again
when he's speaking about his
resurrection and the in the third day of
Resurrection he's always bringing
connecting with the aspect of being
delivered into the hands of man
precisely so when we this expression of
being in the heart of the earth is not
meaning that he has to be in the Tomb
for three days literal days night and
days right it means the whole process of
him as you mentioned being in captivity
being delivered from his freedom
submitting to that cruel
death experience as I remember he even
died in a sense he became sin for us in
not at Calvary yeah you know so it's a
very subtle it's a nuanced understanding
but it's very very important these two
protects that these two texts that you
chose don't even single out in the Tomb
no it it it talks about the whole
process from the time he is taken to the
time he's resurrected it's all part of
one thing so the clock starts sticking
not when they roll a stone there that's
just part of the whole scenario the
clock starts ticking on three days when
he's taken to the hands of cruel men and
suffered at the hands of the scribes and
Affairs you see and and pastor and the
third because Christ announced them
three times and the third time again
that's in chapter 20 verse 18 and 19.
if we go there that's the one I have you
have that
again when he mentions the concept of
third day again look what he says there
behold we are going up to Jerusalem and
the son of man will be betrayed to the
chief priests and to the scribes and
they will condemn him to death and
deliver him to the Gentiles to Mock and
discourage and to crucif and to crucify
and the third day he will rise again
that's that's the one that I had uh and
I thank you for the other two yeah but I
had based mine on this one because it
says the same thing as the other two
texts yes basically that it starts with
the scourging and when he's brought into
to to captivity if I can use that term
by the scribes and the Pharisees and the
Jewish leaders and it ends with the
resurrection it's all included in the
process not just going into this room
remember that in that expression the
sign that the generation would demand it
would be not given except the sign of
Jonas right so the the sign was for the
Jewish Nation for the generation that
were there in the time of Christ and the
sign was for him to be to enter any into
this Con experience of
I suppose God himself kind of turning
away from him in a sense being in the
hands of men and allowing this trial
this process of crucifixion even and
death and for him to resurrect and the
third day every time he mentions this or
he talks about the third day is in
regards to that whole experience so if
the expression the heart of the earth is
three days as he's mentioning he's not
just singling out being on the tomb for
three days but he's really speaking
about being in the experience of you
know being rejected being put into trial
being put into
I guess the passion that he had through
you know because we we hear about and so
I think this is important and hopefully
this answers the question that Gene has
any other thoughts Pastor you know it's
it's a nuanced understanding I when I
first hit upon this I was so happy you
know I was just like oh I discovered
stuff no one else has ever discovered
but I found out you discovered it too it
made me have this because Doug Batcher
also believes this yes that that so go
over these three texts that um Pastor
has mentioned and and and let them kind
of speak to you and notice what they do
not say is just as important as what
they do say they do not single out his
time in the Tomb it's the whole package
from the time he is taken to the time he
is resurrected all of that is included
uh in heart of the earth amen Pastor
well we thank you so much for allowing
us to come to your uh homes and for
allowing us to share the word from God
we expect that the Lord will be with you
and will lead you to all truth blessings
to you
[Music]
thank you